for spider-man fans into the
spider-verse was a non-stop parade of
references all revolving around your
favorite web slinger here are even more
small details and easter eggs you might
have missed in into the spider verse and
it should go without saying but we're
saying it anyway swingin Spidey spoilers
ahead Brian Michael Bendis Sarah Peck
Kelly and Steve Ditko aren't the only
spider-man comic book creators to get a
shout out in in to the spider verse one
of the other contacts in miles his phone
is D slot referencing comic book writer
Dan Slott the writer who came up with
the concept of the spider verse for the
comic books meanwhile miles walks past a
ramen shop called Romita ramen partway
through the film
this is a double shout out John Romita
senior was the artist who took over the
art duties on amazing spider-man after
original Spidey artist Steve Ditko left
the title he's also the co-creator of
Mary Jane Watson who appears in the film
and the original version of the Prowler
Hobie Brown his son John Romita Jr
likewise had a long successful run on
amazing spider-man into the spider verse
is also loaded with visual references to
classic comic arcs and character designs
kingpin dominates the screen whenever
he's shown in an obvious reference to
Bill syncovich his famous portrayal and
when Gwen Stacy's Spider Woman appears
the cover of her comic makes sure to
credit her actual creators Jason Latour
Robbie Rodriguez and Rico Renzi it goes
further than just a shout out to Gwen's
flashback sequences are washed over in
kinetic neon pinks and purples a perfect
replication of colorist Rico Renzi's
color scheme in the spider-gwen comic
when the various spider people explore
Aunt May's secret spider bunker you
might have noticed a quick shot of the
spider mobile on one of the platforms in
the comics the spider mobile could drive
along walls and shoot webbing it didn't
last long as Spidey's vehicle of choice
though it was quickly thrashed lost and
of course repurposed by a super villain
to try and kill spider-man one of the
most subtle Easter eggs in the film
comes when Aunt May sees Olivia Octavius
and calls her live as the villain told
spider-man earlier in the film her
enemies call her Doc Ock but her friends
call her Liv the fact that Aunt May
knows and uses doc Ock's nickname hints
at a previous relationship between the
two
but what did that relationship look like
well if miles is universe is anything
like the regular Marvel Universe
chances are the Doc Ock and Aunt May may
have had a pretty close relationship
like almost getting married it all
happened in amazing spider-man number
131 which featured the eight armed
menace nearly marrying Spidey's and in
order to claim a nuclear power plant
that may received from a recent
inheritance may does seem to have a
thing for genius inventors it's so hard
for me to believe that she's someone's
aunt yeah becoming all shapes and sizes
you know this one that date loaf is
exceptions you stop you their fans were
no doubt surprised to see Peter Parker
bite the bullet early on in the film
fans might have been even more surprised
when Peter takes off his mask and his
hair is blonde
instead of the expected brown that's
because the filmmakers are paying
tribute to the original duplicate
spider-man Ben Riley in the comics Riley
was a clone of Peter Parker who dyed his
hair and changed his name to
differentiate himself from the original
Peter Parker while shameik Moore does an
excellent job voicing young Miles
Morales in the film many fans had their
hearts set on donald glover to portray
the young web slinger the atlanta
creator was pushed into the spider
spotlight when he half-jokingly campaign
to play the role of spider-man in 2010
while the role ultimately went to Andrew
Garfield Glover did voice Miles Morales
in the ultimate spider-man cartoon and
he even appeared in spider-man
homecoming as miles as uncle Aaron Davis
the other night you told that dude if
you're gonna shoot somebody shoot me
it's pretty ballsy
I don't want those weapons in this
neighborhood I got a nephew who live
here although my Hershel alley provides
the voice for uncle Aaron and into the
spider-verse the filmmakers found time
to acknowledge Glover's various roles in
a quick Easter Egg when miles goes to
visit his uncle eagle-eyed fans can spot
Aaron watching a few seconds of
community specifically anthropology 101
an episode that features Glover's Troy
Barnes waking up in spider-man pajamas
throughout into the spider-verse
Peter B Parker struggles with the mess
he's made of his life he's sleepwalking
through his days and marking the hours
of pizza boxes and dirty laundry his
downturn is partly because of his split
from Mary Jane for reasons that aren't
explicitly revealed in the film however
if you pay attention
one reason as to why they broke up
becomes apparent he didn't want kids
it's once again a storyline slightly
adjusted from the comic book source
material in the 90s Peter and MJ almost
had a baby before separating for a few
years in the movie it seems like Peters
pretty staunchly anti-spy der baby
however by the end of the film Peter
takes a moment to wonder if he actually
does want kids in one comics timeline he
eventually has a daughter with MJ who he
name's May Parker and she naturally
grows up to be Spider Girl
if Peter and MJ do get back together
following the events of into the spider
verse we wouldn't be surprised to see
may Parker pop up in the sequel or even
in the upcoming Gwen Stacy spider-woman
spin-off
[Music]